Hello, and welcome to my latest course at
the Rawkode Academy.
This is Portainer
in production.
I want to say thank you to Neil
and his team at Portainer
for kindly sponsoring
my time to produce this course.
So what will this course entail?
Over the next few weeks, we will be
diving in to how to run Portainer in
production to manage real production workloads.
We'll be taking a look at some interesting
features of Portainer,
such as fleet management and GitOps,
ditching Kubernetes,
for simpler orchestrators
like Nomad and Swarm,
multi cluster management,
securing your workloads,
and even a live hacking experiment where I
attempt to add OCI
registry support
to enrich the GitOps capabilities of Portainer.
I hope you are as excited as I
am for this Portainer and production course.
Today, we start with our first tutorial,
which is to take an existing Portainer installation
and look at the different ways to manage
the x five zero nine TLS certificates.
Let's have some fun.
So when you install Portainer for the first
time, you're presented with this screen.
This is a vanilla e c two box
running on AWS
with a docker installation of Portainer.
By default, TLS runs on nine four four
three,
and Portainer is very kind. It generates some
self signed certificates so that you can get
started right away in a secure fashion.
But, of course, as we all know with
self signed certificates, our browsers can't
verify
or trust
the route.
So you'll often be presented with this screen
which says your connection is not private.
Now, of course, we can click on advanced
and say proceed,
and this is enough for most.
Of course,
we can improve the situation.
In 2022,
we have access to let's
have free
TLS certificates
all day long.
So in this session, we're gonna take a
look at how we can use cert bot
on the host
to provision the x five zero nines
and have Portainer mount them in to the
Docker container
to replace the self signed certificates.
But that still requires a little bit of
manual work.
So we're gonna take a look at a
second option too,
which is to run a reverse proxy in
front of Portainer,
which can handle
the let's encrypt negotiation,
the let's encrypt dance for you.
And for this, we'll be taking a look
at CATI.
There's no right or wrong answer when it
comes to using
either of these methods.
If you are happy and comfortable with Portainer's
cell sign certificates, then go nuts.
If you don't mind doing a little bit
of plumbing and running cert bot on your
host,
fine by me.
And if you wanna take the extra step
and configure a reverse proxy that manages the
Acme dance for you,
then so be it.
So let's take a look at the different
ways to manage our x five zero nines
for Portainer.
So the first thing we're gonna take a
look at is the settings page.
From the Portainer homepage, if you click on
settings
and scroll down, you will see the SSL
certificate settings.
If you really want an extended validation certificate,
an EV cert, and you wanna go and
pay $500,
this is where you upload it. You select
file for the private key and the certificate,
and you're good to go.
Regardless of which TLS method you use with
your Portainer, I'm gonna recommend
that you tick the force HTTPS
only box and apply.
You don't really want to expose any web
service in this day and age over regular
HTTP.
So let's practice good hygiene and secure it.
Perfect.
Okay.
Now that we have Portainer running
with the self signed certificate and we are
enforcing HTTPS
mode, we can look at alternative ways to
get our own x five zero nine certificates
into the setup.
The first way that I want to show
you
is using cert bot.
If you're not familiar with cert bot, it
is a piece of software
from the team at Let's Encrypt.
This speaks to ACME protocol to the Let's
encrypt servers and issues certificates.
To run certbot on Ubuntu is relatively easy.
It's delivered as a snap application, and snap
is available on all Ubuntu machines.
So first, we run snap install core.
We then do a snap refresh core.
This will update the snap package list, allowing
us to install the latest version of certbot.
Next, we run snap install certbot.
Only we're gonna pass the dash dash classic
flag.
Dash dash classic just means that we're going
to run certbot with access to the host
and no c groups or namespace constraints.
We then make sure that cert bot is
available as a system command
on the regular path by moving it or
creating a symbolic link to user bin.
Next, we run cert bot cert only standalone.
What does this mean? Well, it means it's
going to run its own web server on
the host because the way the ACME protocol
works. If you want a certificate
for a domain,
it must be able to reach
that server on that domain on port 80,
where it will respond with a key to
confirm that you actually have access and the
ability
to provision certificates for that domain.
It's a proof of ownership
or at least administration.
This is an interactive command, and when we
run it, it's going to ask us for
our email address and the domain that we
wish to provision the certificate for.
Now we wanna be able to automate the
renewal of these certificates, and we don't wanna
have to have any manual intervention.
So we're gonna use system d timers with
a system d service to make sure that
once a month, the certificate is checked to
see if it's going to expire.
Here, we create a certbot timer,
which is going to run the certbot service
on the first day of every month, a
quarter past three in the morning.
Then we have a cert bot service, which
runs cert bot renew.
Simple.
We do a daemon reload and enable our
timer.
Now don't worry about pausing and copying or
typing everything that you've seen in that file
there. The code is available at github.com/rawcodeacademy/portainer-in-production.
The link
is there.
So let's run our start bot script.
First, it asks for email address. I'll enter
david@rawkode.com.
Yes. I agree to the terms. Yes. I'll
share my email address, and now it's asking
for the domain that we wish to secure.
I'm going to enter p.Rawkode.academy
because that is the DNS that I have
configured for this machine running our Portainer instance.
Let's encrypt is now running a web server
on this machine on Port 80, sending a
request looking for a file available over HTTP
that confirms that I have administration's right to
this domain.
As you can see, it successfully created our
certificate in the slash ETC slash lesson crypt
slash live folder,
meaning this is a real production lesson crypt
certificate that is now available
for Portainer to use.
Now if you remember in our system d
timer,
we have a command configured called certbot renew.
I'm got not going to run renew now,
so I'm going to pass the dry run
flag.
But this is the command that will check
for the expiration date on your certificates and
make sure
that as they're close to being expired, they
will be renewed for another three months.
Also, if you're looking at the commands I've
typed and you don't want to run this
script in an interactive environment,
all the arguments that I passed, my email
address, those remain and a green to the
terms can be configured
through flags passed to the certbot command.
If you run certbot cert only dash dash
help,
everything you need to know is there.
So let's configure
Portainer
to use these new let's encrypt certificates.
Also available on the GitHub as a script.
So here we have the Docker commands with
the correct volume mounts to take less encrypt
certificates from the host into your Portainer instance.
The two mounts that we worried about or
the two mounts that we are concerned about
are these two here. The ones with etcetera,
let's encrypt live and etcetera, let's encrypt archive.
You'll see that we have the term your
domain.
This is in the middle and end of
each of these mount lines.
So you can use search and replace to
find your domain and replace it with the
domain you're running Portainer on.
We save,
Now we can run our p dot l
e script, which will run Portainer
over
TLS
with let's encrypt production certificate.
So if we pop over to the browser,
hit refresh,
click on unlock,
you will see our certificate is issued by
r three, the let's encrypt authority.
Awesome.
Now there's not a lot of maintenance with
that approach, and you can be very successful
with Portainer's own self signed certificates
or let's encrypt running on a host.
But I think my preferred way is to
use KADI as a reverse proxy,
which does automatic
TLS for you. It speaks ACME to let's
encrypt and handles all the renewals for you.
We don't even need to disable the Portainer
cell sign certificates,
and we can still enforce TLS at all
times.
It just means that you, as the user
with a browser, speak TLS to Caddy via
the less than 10 production certificate.
But it also means that Caddy speaks to
Portainer over TLS using the self signed certificate.
So we have end to end TLS encrypted
web traffic.
So I created a small script also available
on the GitHub page,
p-rp.sh.
Here, you'll see the complete setup for this
Portainer configuration.
First, I remove all the containers from the
host.
Maybe don't copy that line.
We then create the volume for Portainer, which
I've already done as part of configuration, so
it's commented out.
We then run Portainer as always. Only this
time, there are no volume mounts for let's
encrypt certificates.
For CADI, we also need two volumes,
CADI data and CADI config.
From there, we can run CADI,
making sure that we bind ports four four
three and eighty from the container to the
host. Remember, for let's encrypt ACME negotiations,
we must have physical port 80 available on
the host.
We also need to link
Portainer
with the name Portainer.
This means that DNS queries from the CADI
container can query Portainer as a DNS name
and reach the Portainer container.
We then have to mount in our caddy
file, which I'll show you in just a
moment to slash e t c slash caddy
slash caddy file.
We then mount in the two volumes we
created, CADI data and CADI config.
As you'll see, I'm using the official CADI
two dash Alpine image.
If we take a look at the CADI
file, we'll see, one, we have to configure
our email address. This is because emails are
required for admin negotiations with Let's Encrypt.
We then set up a virtual host of
p.Rawkode.academy.
We have a reverse proxy block which says,
hey. Any request we get on this domain,
we're gonna proxy to another server.
We specify the two, which is going to
our Portainer on port 993,
the encrypted self signed certificate Portainer.
Because it's a self signed certificate, we do
have to tell CADI not to verify
the route.
So we need a transport block for HTTP
where we see a TLS is enabled. However,
skip the verification step.
And that is it.
We can run PRP,
which will delete any existing containers,
start up the two new containers,
and in fact, we can run Docker container
l s. We'll see that we have caddy
and Portainer both running.
And now if we do a curl with
a dash dash v
to p.Rawkode.Academy,
we get a whole bunch of text back.
This is a good indication that things are
working.
Let's pop back over to the browser
and refresh, and you'll see that we still
have a happy lock
with a certificate issued
by r three from Let's Encrypt.
So that is how you enable and secure
your Portainer instance three ways.
One,
using their self signed certificates.
It works as long as you don't mind
clicking accept or advanced
on that little warning page, you're good to
go.
Two,
cert bot on the host with a system
d timer to handle renewals.
And three, reverse proxy with Caddy.
They're all production grade. They're all good to
go.
Enjoy. We'll see you next time.